the elites have never accepted the fact
that populist conservatives and economic
nationalists around the globe are on
their eyes here in the US think about it
the deep state rose up against Trump
during and after the election by using
informants the FISA Court surveillance
powers and a Special Counsel
investigation two years 35 million
dollars to try to oust him from office
in the end we're gonna find out that the
Obama DOJ did a lot more to hurt America
than some pathetic Russian hackers ever
could
and ever since Trump was elected the
global establishment has suffered from
wishful thinking syndrome a huge blow to
the wave of populism that helps with
Donald Trump into office nationalism
versus globalism and in this case the
growing tide of populism appears to have
receded no question this was a big blow
to what's being called know-nothing
populism you can't look at this election
and any other way but to see it as a
repudiation of Trump oh whoops
how can so many people get paid to be so
consistently wrong and they're supposed
to be experts of course you might have
heard over the weekend populist
nationalist made stunning gains in the
EU elections especially in Britain now
remember three years ago Nigel Farage of
the UK party forced a referendum where
the voters chose to leave the European
Union the so-called brexit but ever
since then the establishment parties
have done everything in their power to
slow things down or just to try to
thwart the will of the people altogether
and now two prime ministers later the
people still don't have their
independence from the bureaucrats in
Brussels
well just six weeks ago Faraj came back
out of retirement and founded the brexit
party and in a stunning rebuke of the
old labor and conservative parties it
won nearly 32 percent of the vote and
captured 29 seats in the European
Parliament with other parties basically
obliterated
it was the worst national election for
Teresa Mays conservative party ever
well like the Trump victory back in 2016
Farraj led an insurgent campaign and he
stuck to his message the UK wants out of
the EU well in the end at the end of the
day it's about what voters want
and I think either either the
conservative or Labour Party's take us
towards brexit or they're gonna have to
be replaced as as simple as that
in France marine lepen National Rally
Party beat out macarons pro-eu centrist
party winning the most french seats at
the EU nationalists and Italy also took
the most seats and all over Europe
people are demanding their freedom from
the international shackles put on by far
away regulators who don't know and can't
respond to their country their people or
their needs now while most are fine to
have strong economic relationships with
their member nations the populist the
more economic nationalists among them
still want to retain their language
their borders and their own unique
culture and when you read the New York
Times though or CNN you listen to them
they always use the phrase
anti-immigrant or far-right parties made
the games almost invariably that
description is false again the slime is
being thrown at Trump or salvini or
Lipan or Viktor Orban and Hungary and
it's meant only to denigrate not to
advance an actual debate about how to
improve people's standard of living
time after time rather than listen to
the people and use the moments that
these moments as an opportunity to learn
and change instead the global elites
just run in the other direction and I
think of Angela Merkel the woman
responsible for Europe's admission of 1
million plus refugees and let's face it
that has been a disaster from Italy to
Sweden and everywhere in between now the
German Chancellor seems to have learned
nothing and she answered a reporter's
question and that reporter was
fully in denial under your nearly 15
years in power in some cases those dark
old demons have risen again Germany can
and will not uncouple itself from
developments we see all over the world
we see this in Germany as well but in
Germany obviously they always have to be
seen in a certain context in the context
of our past which means we have to be
that much more vigilant than others we
have to tell our young people what
history has brought over us and others
and these horrors the horrors well in
other words if you voted for a populist
or nationalist party you're essentially
in some way empathizing with what Hitler
or Hitler and waiting it's ridiculous
Italian Deputy Prime Minister Mamata
Matteo salvini who led the Italian
populist nationalist to historic gains
in the EU had the perfect response in
the Italia francha in gilt era a senior
dinner Apogee can vote oh the ultra
popular opiod Ottoman dato quiero Liga
de tolly Adela di zucca Sione F Aleta
estado bachata tsipras English or
American macron Theresa May Oh boohoo la
grappa della pre-created esta muchacha
yeah the elites are being rejected
because they failed
they've been routed and worse results
are coming their way because they refuse
to hear the voters now as Trump is shown
here at home a strong muscular approach
on trade lower taxes fewer regulations
and a foreign policy based in prude and
realism it's all paying off check out
our economy compared to Europe's
basically no comparison whatsoever look
at that EU 1.5 percent GDP u.s. 3.2
percent GDP unemployment about almost
double in Europe translation Trump's
policies work as the European model
barely limps along now wonder the
European voters are restless look for
more
big moves against the old guard to come
in 2020 and beyond the fight has just
begun and that's the angle